[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: When you're ready to
start solving on the cloud,
the Google Cloud free program
is a great place to start.
So what does that
actually include?
Once you create
your new account,
you'll have $300 in credits
for the first 90 days
to use across all
of Google Cloud.
And don't worry.
Even once you've
used your credits
or finished your
90 days, you won't
be charged unless you
manually upgrade your account.
Once you upgrade, you'll
keep your Cloud resources
and any remaining credits.
Plus, with the free tier,
new and existing users
can take advantage of many
of Google Cloud services
entirely for free.
These services can be used
within a monthly limit,
letting you build and
test new solutions
on innovative
technology, including
running virtual machines,
serverless container
hosting, or data analysis
entirely for free.
Each service has
different limits,
so try them out without
worrying about costs.
On top of all that, you'll also
get $200 in monthly credits
towards usage of Google
Maps Platform products.
Get started with
Google Cloud for free.
[MUSIC PLAYING]